a damn good writer a caring son and a
bisexual man he writes about that moment
much more in his new book it's called
The Yards between us A Memoir of life
love and football r.k Russell we're very
happy to say is here for his first
interview about the book good to see you
Mr Russell we're glad to have you at the
table thank you for having me you're
right in detail you've been through a
lot in your life you were bullied as a
kid you lost a father uh you you dated
women you were talking about that then
you met the love of your life but you
said many times in your life you had to
struggle between your private personal
life in your public Football Life what
do you mean by that
I would say my football life and my
football Persona comes with certain
expectations you know as a player Oh to
be you know masculine to be tough to
date women
um you know to be kind of this apex
predator of men and I say my private
life when I really mean private you know
we would keep things to yourself don't
everybody need to know everything about
what you do but when that privacy is
more of a secret secrets are shrouded
more than shame
and when you start to attribute that to
to parts of yourself like the people
that you love your relationships people
things that should bring Pride
um shame just makes it a very dark place
a lonely Place were you ashamed
I think definitely had a part you know a
lot what we hear especially from
male football culture yeah uh is about
this toxic masculine that we're all
finally having conversations about also
just the mental Wellness aspect I think
Secrets shame shrouding all of that in
darkness is detrimental to your mental
health it's detrimental to your private
and public life you know Persona and um
really just creates a riff in in oneself
now speaking of those words toxic
masculinity you touch on it there are
certain locker rooms where you might
hear certain things and you feel like
the maturity of the team isn't where it
needs to be to deal with real issues
that one individual on the team might be
dealing with but then there's other
locker rooms and teams that I've
experienced where it was welcoming and
embracing where do you believe the NFL
is at now as it pertains to players that
might want to come out I think the NFL
is definitely being more intentional
about making that space feel more
welcoming same I've been in locker rooms
that have been very welcoming very open
in the locker rooms that haven't really
weren't hateful I didn't feel like a
fear for my life I think it was just
carelessness it's not that intention to
make sure that that lgbtq plus athlete
specifically feel included um so I think
the NFL's definitely be more intense and
by locker rooms do you mean the entirety
of the team or is it more individuals
yeah that are dealing with certain
issues a different way I'd say it's
definitely I'd say it's an organization
honestly because there are so many
generations especially in the
organizations we have young players
coming in you know who are raised a
certain way we have coaches who may be
coached for 20 30 40 years you know
coming in with raised a certain way in
their own preconceived notions so
there's a mix of generations they're
kind of like you get with a family yeah
I was gonna speaking of family because
in addition to football issues you also
had issues within your own family for
instance right before that article came
out you told your mother for the first
time because it was going to make
national news you wanted your mother to
know so you said Mom I have something to
tell you I'm bisexual and you said her
response three words that came out of
her mouth were the most devastating and
see I thought she was going to say I
always knew that's what I thought she
was going to say but what did she say to
you RK what about football yeah and for
me it was devastating was also a mirror
because that's how I lived my life I had
always put football first you know
before my own well-being before my
relationships so it was really a mirror
of of how I had taught everyone in my
life to see me yeah you know my mother's
here with me today we've always been
close we'll continue to be close but I
think it's important to point out
shortly after she said that she came to
you and said I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
that that was my reaction I I love you
what I feel about you I think it's
important that she course corrected very
quickly and my mom and I think as most
parents do they care about the things
that we care about as well so she knew
that football was important to me so so
that was kind of her but her reaction is
so revealing actually about what we all
expect from football right exactly and I
know four years ago is when you came out
today I think you'd probably say things
are different I'd love to hear what you
think about a player today if they came
out how they'd be received but for you
yourself do you think coming out
contributed to the end of your active
NFL career
you know I'm not sure I I think
historically we see players come out
either after their career so they come
out at some point in it and they don't
play again
um but like I say in the book I I rather
Chase Joy the conspiracy I can't say
what the reasons are because I can say
this one thing and a team can bring up
three four five other reasons that any
player would not get yeah they're good
at that yeah I like that brother pace
you'd rather Chase Joy than conspiracy
it's interesting too that you describe
yourself as bisexual because early on in
the book you clearly did date women you
had a very significant relation Whitney
was her name and then later on you met
Corey you met other men and you decided
that I this is this is who I love now
where do you stand today how do you feel
today we should say Corey's here too
shout out to Corey Corey's here too
serious um the great thing about hi
Corey
Corey and your mom together yes the
great thing about identity is our
partners don't Define that for us I'm no
less black because I'm dating a white
man I'm no less bisexual because I'm
dating a man or a woman
um so I still very much feel comfortable
with my bisexuality that's who I am I
have a great capacity to love different
types of people but right now I've I'm
with the love of my life yes and you
said don't say retired football players
say former football player do you have
any desire to to play football again or
do you feel you're better off doing what
you're doing now it's a bit of both I
definitely have that desire I love I
love football I always love football and
I feel like I can still physically play
um but there's so much that I've been
able to do so many lives I've been able
to touch and dreams that were literally
dreams not even goals where dreams for
me have started to unravel in and come
true so it would be harder I think
before I would pick up the phone and no
matter what I would drop everything
right now it would be like oh well I
don't know I got I got some stuff that
you say you opened up the new chapter
yes exactly all right cheering you on in
your new chapter r.k Russell thank you
very much thank you do you mind if we
mention the book again please hold up
the yard between us look at all our
Graphics here RK goes on sale today
wherever you like to buy your books